la livraison est un peu tardive et
l'installation plutôt complexe
au niveau des centres de service
scolaire puis c'est correct dans le fond
ils font leur travail ils ont dû refaire
des soumissions avec les prix actuels du
béton le prix des matériaux il fallait
attendre aussi que ça soit installé
pendant une journée pédagogique pour que
ça soit sécuritaire pour les enfants
depuis 3 ans l'enseignante Marie-Émilie
gagné rêve de ses modules pour la cour
de l'école Saint-Louis de Gonzague moi
je voulais avoir un skatepark pour
donner mes cours parascolaire de skate
et pour que les enfants à un endroit
sécuritaire pour pratiquer aussi donc
des modules de bon niveau pour leur
permettre d'évoluer il n'y a
pratiquement pas de parcours à Montréal
pour les débutants planches à roulettes
c'est pourtant un sport attrayant qui
amène fait son entrée aux Jeux
olympiques en 2021 à Tokyo j'ai plutôt
comme essayer le skate parce que genre
je connais pas vraiment ça mais
j'aimerais ça en apprendre davantage
qu'est-ce que j'aime dans le skate c'est
comme faire les rampes c'est amusant
parce que comme tu glisse
c'est une vraiment bonne sensation le
renseignante il voit beaucoup plus que
le côté coule
et c'est un bon âge pour apprendre ils
sont assez grands ces matures pour être
capable de d'être focaliser longtemps
concentré bien écouter les conseils
aussi de placement du corps
on encourageant les jeunes à répéter les
essais à tomber sans se blesser à
persévérer l'enseignante de 40 ans a
retrouvé des valeurs qu'il lui sont
chères il est valeurs de la persévérance
de la confiance en soi de l'entraide se
retrouver aussi à l'école je me suis dit
pourquoi pas faire un parascolaire de
planche à roulettes à l'école pour
ramener ses valeurs là dans un sport qui
pour moi est un sport complet il y a des
écoles où il y a des équipes de sport
mais nous c'était comme si on était
genre une école de skate parce qu'on est
skateboard puis on a des cours l'école
prête les planches à roulettes et les
casques aux élèves le projet réalisé par
une firme spécialisée représente un
investissement de 31000 dollars j'ai eu
un petit montant de l'arrondissement ici
du Plateau Mont-Royal et le reste c'est
des fonds dans le fond qui avait été
accumulé par les parents des années
précédentes une passionnée alors je
pense que à nous a tous convaincu c'est
déjà
un projet qui a fait des heureux parce
qu'en fait semaine je suis passé samedi
et dimanche j'ai eu plaisir de voir des
petites familles et plein d'enfants en
trottinette essayez le skatepark donc ça
va être ton véhicule que c'est une bonne
idée finalement et que ça répondait à un
besoin j'ai découvert le skate à 35 ans
suite au défi d'une amie qui m'a dit de
réussir un lit qui est une figure en
skate où est-ce qu'on doit faire sauter
notre planche dans les airs en une
semaine et j'ai réussi et je suis
vraiment tombé en amour avec le sport
c'est cool parce que tu peux venir ce
qui était la fin de semaine et puis ça
ça donne des plus larges espaces pour
faire des figures
il y a déjà eu quelques plates au sujet
du bruit provoqués par les joints
métalliques l'hiver laissera un peu de
temps pour trouver un accommodement
[Musique]
ici Anne-Louise des taxis Radio-Canada